Steve Irwin there's a name you never
forget one of Australia's most famous
faces and since he died his family been
working tirelessly to continue his
legacy of conservation and education and
now their work at the sunshine zoo in
Australia is being turned into a new TV
series have a look it's really more of a
resort for wildlife you're able to
experience them hands-on see them you
feel them you discover a koala smells
like eucalyptus encouraging people to
fall in love with wildlife make a
difference on the planet with everything
that we did we're ultimately trying to
continue dad's legacy we really are
kicking the gulls that he originally
said
[Music]
I'm delighted to say to be Owens Terry
bindi and Robert are here we love it
here do you yes I have stopped drinking
coffee and I've taken up tea crocodiles
and snakes
no it's still lovely there's lots of
squirrels
we don't have squirrels in Australia
okay yeah gotta say Robert you're a chip
off the old block yeah very much so just
every day more I remember I was going
through some old photos and I got a
photograph out and said what do you
think of this and he goes that's a photo
of me yeah it's not it's a young dad
photo yeah
what's interesting though is that it is
the family obviously we knew what Steve
did and and and his passion for nature
what we didn't realize at the time
necessarily was how that was a family
wide sort of venture yes no he was
definitely larger than life and we're
very proud to be carrying on with what
he started its June was so special is
that to everyone dad was the ultimate
wildlife warrior but to us he was the
greatest dad and to be able to carry on
in his footsteps and make sure that his
legacy lives on forever is such a
blessing it's what we love it's not just
what we do it's who we are
so wildlife conservation work at
Australia Zoo is so special and now we
have our brand-new show crikey it's the
Aaron's with Animal Planet we certainly
passed down his enthusiasm it's just
bursting at the screen and you very much
grew up around animals didn't you and we
very famously saw the clip I think was
when your dad held you new to a
crocodile it was so much fun there
because dad always included us in on
everything and so does mum and I think
that that gave us the most amazing gift
where we were able to travel with our
family and experience wildlife and
conservation work all over the world and
it kind of gave us the opportunity to
see outside our own little bubbles and
we all tend to get caught up in our
bubbles but we have to
but as a society we have to work
together to create positive change for
the generations to come so this wild
life and as we tragically know wildlife
can be very dangerous how do you
incorporate that we would know that
we'll see bits in in the TV show of you
dealing with the Crocs and worst of it
but how do you balance that out because
the part the beauty of wildlife is its
inherent danger mm-hmm oh absolutely and
I think for for me a passion that we've
always had is really showing kind of the
other side to these more sort of scary
animals things like crocodiles our apex
predators animals that people see as you
know they're just these mindless hunting
killing machines that's that's not true
at all crocodiles they're my favorite
animal and they really are intelligent
creatures they're great mothers they're
very caring towards one another so
really what we're trying to do in this
new series is kind of show wildlife in a
different light and show how you can
form this this connection this bond with
each animal and really show just how
amazing and important they are because I
think there's never been a time in
history that's been more important to
conserve our wildlife I mean numbers are
depleting so much we need to make sure
that we have them on earth forever but
do you have a respectful fear if you
like of the animals as well I mean it
you must at some point have reservation
about dealing face-to-face with
crocodiles and other dangerous animals I
think for me I've always felt it kind of
as this respect like you have to have so
much respect for these creatures because
crocodiles have been on the planet for
200 million years they are such amazing
animals so if you can have this this
respect for them and really learn the
the rules of crocodiles
so for me I'm learning how to feed them
and how to work alongside them and it's
so fun and exciting and I get to educate
people about them so it's it's really
great but you certainly have to have no
ego it's not about you it's about the
animal and you really have to respect
that I mean it's it's the difference
isn't it between what we would
traditionally think of a circus and
circus animals and and in a way they
almost conflated at one stage in history
didn't leave but zoos have become now
sanctuaries rather than places just to
go and peer and prod and poke you know
what's so exciting too is the behind the
scene so when we're working with our
wildlife it's all natural behavior and
big expanse of areas and everything gets
out of its enclosures the Tigers go for
walks and the rhinos have 30 acres to
play on and that's that's what's
important in what's new and different
but behind the scenes is the the science
and the work we're doing to protect
wildlife through research and habitat
protection and anti poaching units and
all the work that goes on behind the
scenes that's what you don't see up
front and that's why this shows so fun
because you can go wow I never knew this
was happening like the anti poaching
unit in Africa that we support that's
all women they're amazing and yes yes we
proposed these kind of things that zoos
support that you don't see when you walk
into it there you are it's so important
in the show we'll take you there so we
actually go to Africa to see what's
going on on the ground and really see
the problems that are happening and how
those like Australia Zoo are hoping to
support yeah I love the way you describe
it as a resort for wildlife that that
really does encapsulate it doesn't it
really no it's it's different now and it
needs to be so with us our animals
always come first then our team and then
our visitors so when you come in you see
really happy healthy animals that are
having a great day and you can love on
everything and they have so much
enrichment that's the future and really
if you can get animals into your heart
it makes you more appreciative and
tolerant and respectful of people that's
what it's all I'll tell you what you
three definitely make me want to come to
Australia really want to go to teri I've
got to ask you because I mean can't
imagine how difficult it is to lose a
partner and to raise children on your
own although all that that entails
Steve would have been so proud of these
two oh I'll say I mean bindi and Robert
art have been just amazing stepping up
and being passionate about wildlife and
conservation and so respectful of their
dad and
his message and mission and to want to
carry on in what he started just really
warms my heart and I couldn't be more
proud of so I have to say it's because
we have Wonder Woman for a mum I mean
surely mums strength and determination
to continue on has been such an
inspiration for us so as a family dad
first came up with the term wildlife
warrior and I really believe that's who
we are we stand up and speak for those
who cannot speak for themselves
so together we want to change the world
and help to encourage everyone to make a
difference in their own backyards and
we're so proud to be continuing on in
dad's footsteps
it's really good to see you books are
tickets please